cuál es la solución a la desigualdad x 5
mayor a 14
eso se resuelve como cualquier ecuación
o igualdad lo que hacemos de un lado lo
hacemos del otro lado también me quiero
deshacer de este menos 5 así que vamos a
sumar 5 en ambos lados de esta ecuación
lo voy a escribir voy a sumar 5 5
x menos 5 que es esta parte y esto sigue
siendo mayor que 14 más 5 estamos
sumando 5 en ambos lados de esta
desigualdad estos dos se van que ese es
mi intención y me queda x mayor que 14
más 5 va a ser 19 así que esta es la
solución que es la opción b veamos el
siguiente problema el 15
tenemos este triángulo donde un lado es
tamaño y el otro lado es más uno y este
lado de acá abajo es siete centímetros
nos dicen que el perímetro es de 56
centímetros y nos preguntan cuál es el
valor de y bueno sabemos que el
perímetro va a ser igual a la suma de
todos los lados de cualquier figura
geométrica
vamos a expresar esto tenemos que el
perímetro es la suma de todos los lados
será ya que es un lado más el otro lado
qué es
+ 1
más siete centímetros que lo que mide el
otro lado debe ser igual todo esto a 56
centímetros ya que esto es el perímetro
vamos a simplificar esto ye más ya va a
ser igual a 217 es igual a 8 y esto es
igual a 56
quiero conocer el valor de y vamos a
restar 8 en ambos lados de esta ecuación
aquí pongo menos 8
más esto y aquí menos 8
estos dos se van y me quedan lo voy a
escribir aquí dos igual a 56 menos ocho
va a ser igual a 48 48 finalmente para
poder encontrar voy a dividir todo entre
2 esto entre 2 esto entre 2 esto se
vuelve uno me queda igual a 48 entre 224
el valor de g es 24 es talleres 24 y
este pues demás 124 más 1 será 25 estos
7 y la suma debe ser igual a 56
bueno continuamos con el siguiente
problema
número sirve de contra ejemplo del
siguiente enunciado todos los enteros
positivos son divisibles entre 2 o 3
bueno contra ejemplos se refiere a que
es algo que contradice o niega lo que
afirma este enunciado bueno vamos a
probar cada una de estas opciones
si en entre 1250 es una división exacta
así que este no me sirve 57 no es
divisible entre 2 pero si es divisible
entre 3 así que este tampoco nos sirve
estos son no nos sirven 30 obviamente es
divisible entre 3 y entre 2 así que éste
tampoco nos sirve nuestra última opción
25 no es divisible entre 2 y tampoco lo
63 de hecho es divisible entre 55 por 5
25 así que esta opción de es nuestro
contra ejemplo que contradice ese
enunciado ok pasamos al siguiente
problema que es el número 17 vamos a
colocarlo aquí
cuál es la conclusión del enunciado que
se muestra a continuación
tenemos si x cuadrada es igual a 4
entonces x es igual a menos 2 x es igual
a 2 y tenemos estas opciones bueno si
sabemos que x al cuadrado es igual a 4
entonces sabemos y esto lo sabemos del
álgebra que esto implica
x va a ser igual a 2 o que x va a ser
igual a menos 2 ya que cualquiera de
estas dos al cuadrado nos da 4
así que cuál es la conclusión del
anunciado bueno esta de aquí esta es la
condición y esta de aquí esta es la
conclusión realmente lo que nos piden en
este problema es etiquetar la conclusión
que de las opciones que vemos es ésta la
de x igual a menos 2x igualados
esta pregunta no me agrada mucho pues mi
primera reacción fue pensar que si todo
esto es el enunciado que puedo concluir
de él y pues no hay mucho que se pueda
concluir para no complicarnos entendamos
que nos dicen que si esta primera parte
se cumple entonces la conclusión será
ésta
muy bien el siguiente problema
de las siguientes es una conclusión
válida del enunciado si una estudiante
es miembro de la banda de música escolar
entonces el estudiante es un buen músico
así que vamos a escribir las condiciones
que nos dicen
que si eres un miembro de la banda de
música escolar implica que eres buen
músico buen músico
músico si comparamos esto con la
pregunta anterior podría causar
confusión por lo que se refiere a
conclusión válida uno podría pensar que
la conclusión del anunciado y ustedes
dirían a el estudiante pues es buen
músico pero no es lo que nos están
pidiendo aquí lo que nos dicen es que si
todo esto es un anunciado que es cierto
de que si un estudiante es miembro de la
banda de música escolar que también
escribía abreviado acá sí sabemos que
esto es verdad cuál de estas opciones
será una conclusión válida la opción a
todos los buenos músicos son miembros de
la banda de música escolar no tiene que
ver con lo que nos dice el enunciado
pues todos los buenos músicos que
podemos hacer un diagrama aquí este es
el universo de los buenos músicos y los
que son parte de la banda de música
escolar puede ser sólo un subconjunto de
estos
esos son los que están en la banda de
música escolar
estos de aquí afuera de estos círculos
morados es todo el universo de los
buenos músicos
buenos
chicos
así que esta primera opción pues
realmente no es una conclusión válida
está la quitamos
la ve un estudiante es miembro de la
banda de música escuelas hoy
correcta porque el enunciado no nos dice
que todos los estudiantes estén en la
banda de música si dibujamos el diagrama
del universo de los estudiantes
la podemos poner más o menos así
estos son los estudiantes
el universo de estudiantes
antes
pues como vemos pueden haber aunque
quizá un poquito desproporcionado pero
de este universo podemos tener
estudiantes que están aquí y ni siquiera
son buenos músicos o estudiantes que son
buenos músicos pero que no se encuentran
en la banda de música escolar así que
por esto descartamos la opción b la
opción se todos los estudiantes son
buenos músicos bueno este mismo diagrama
nos dice que podemos tener estudiantes
que ni siquiera tienen algún talento
musical que están completamente fuera
del universo de los buenos músicos y
también fuera de la banda de música así
que no todos los estudiantes son buenos
músicos está también la descartamos y
nos queda que todos los miembros de la
banda de música escolar son buenos
músicos que es una opción válida este es
el universo de la banda de música
escolar que se encuentra dentro del
universo de los buenos músicos así que
esta opción d
si es una conclusión válida para este
enunciado pasemos al siguiente problema
que es el número 19 y nos dice la
siguiente tabla muestra una expresión
evaluada para cuatro valores diferentes
de x tenemos aquí los valores de x y la
evaluación de estos valores en esta
ecuación que son estos resultados juan
concluyó que para todo valor positivo de
x x cuadrada más x + 5 produce un número
primo si ustedes recuerdan los números
primos son aquellos números que solo son
divisibles entre sí mismos y entre 1 que
el valor de x servirá de contra ejemplo
para la falsa conclusión de juana y
tenemos cada una de estas opciones
recordamos que un contraejemplo es algo
que no cumple con lo que se afirma en
este enunciado en este caso de que cada
valor positivo me genera aquí un número
primo
cual esas opciones lo prueba como falso
analicemos la primera opción 5
sustituyamos 5 en esta ecuación
5 como xx al cuadrado entonces el 5 al
cuadrado 5.5 25
más x que 5
+ 5
esto me da igual 25 5 35 35 35 no es un
número primo ya que este 35 es divisible
entre 5 así que este no es primo
no es primo
no prima y claramente la conclusión es
incorrecta por lo que nuestra opción de
contra ejemplo es ah
pasemos a nuestra última pregunta de
este vídeo
la solución de jose a una ecuación se
muestra a continuación
dado x cuadrada + 5 x 6 igual a 0
el primer paso fue x 2 x x + 3 igual a 0
el segundo paso es x + 2 igual a cero o
x + 3 igual a 0 y el tercer paso x igual
a menos 2 o x y buena menos 3
o de propiedad de los números reales sus
ojos en el segundo paso aquí lo que nos
están pidiendo es justificar y explicar
cómo pasamos de este primer paso a este
segundo paso bueno vamos a analizarlo
aquí ver qué propiedades o jose la
propiedad de igualdad de la
multiplicación bueno de hecho ésta ni
siquiera sé qué significa la propiedad
de igualdad así que esta la quitamos
la segunda opción propiedad del producto
cero de la multiplicación bueno este
podría sonar un poco lógico vamos a
ponerlo aquí a marcarlo
de propiedad conmutativa de la
multiplicación de hecho este no aplica
si fuera justificada del paso del paso 2
al paso 1 así a lo mejor si usaría esta
propiedad conmutativa de la
multiplicación
y la última opción bueno así que la cee
la tachó no sé no me sirve de propiedad
distributiva de la multiplicación sobre
la adición esto no tiene nada que ver
con el problema así que la quitamos de
aquí nuestro inciso b es la propiedad
correcta porque es la propiedad correcta
bueno vamos a analizar aquí nuestro
enunciado o nuestra ecuación
tenemos que queremos analizar a partir
de este paso eso está bien suponemos que
x + 2 es un número
y x3 va a ser otro número que lo voy a
llamar b
este será b y este será
a por b nos está diciendo que esto va a
ser igual a 0 igual a 0
como es posible que este resultado sea 0
ya sea que a es 0 o b es 0 o ambos sean
0 que al multiplicarse nos den 0 y de
ahí es donde viene este segundo paso en
donde se aplica la propiedad de
productos cero de la multiplicación